I'm gonna start by saying how much I
enjoy this show and the first three
episodes of that I saw of season 3 are
really well done for all of you how much
I know that sometimes he shows you
sometimes have a lot of scripts in
advance and sometimes you're getting a
week-by-week
how much did you know about the arc of
the season how many scripts did you have
going in I mean well I well I came on
board everyone's different like Eric
always said Eric show right now he came
and he said look if you want to know
about the arc of your character for a
season I will let you know if you don't
wanna know I won't let you know I like
to know what's going on very nosy I like
to know so I can just look at other
people and be like yeah I know it was
going on there and then in terms of
scripts we get them like a week yeah
about a week before we start you in the
episode um for you guys how much did you
know about the arc and how much did you
want to know I wanted to know in general
terms but I quite like not knowing and
letting it develop because we were
shooting
you know episode by episode in sequence
so it was quite nice to let it let some
things be surprises too and also what's
happening with the other characters and
then how you react to them and sometimes
it for me it's good to have that element
of letting it letting it happen yeah I'm
the same I like to try to stay in the
moment as much as possible but you have
to know I have to know some things I
have to cover more on tropes but yeah I
mean there are areas in which you need
to know a certain structure because
there's a lot going on so you need to
know okay this sequence is going to be
this you need to understand that and if
that sequence takes over two scripts
then it's important to know what's going
on in those two scripts just so it makes
sense to you but then most things I feel
the same way it's you know it's in
general they give I get a general
feeling but I don't want to know
specifics of each script unless of
course it's the sequence that I have to
I have because I need to know the
beginning the middle end of it you know
sure um I absolutely loved your
portrayal of kingpin
I think kingpin is such a great villain
on this show when did you know that you
the character would be coming back in
season three and I'll just start with
that
well Jeff love is very good at keeping
me informed about things he's our he's
the head of television over there Marvel
and he keeps he gives me months at a
time in advance so that I know about to
clear my schedule and stuff like that so
I knew for awhile and he gave me a he
always gives me a very quick idea of
what the season is gonna be because he
as well knows that I don't want to know
everything and so he just says you know
you're gonna come back for all 13 and
then and then this is when we want to do
it and so I know pretty pretty much way
before one of the things that I really
enjoy about this show is all the
characters are just very well-written
well-rounded you get a sense that you
really know these people
talk a little bit about working with
Eric and you know how much was on the
page how much did you like read the
script and suggest you know I mean like
that collaboration with Eric but just
also just the character work well first
J Duck can't read so I read it to him
because he used to play football and
most of those guys can't read and so he
Jewish pictures as well my response
pictures a lot of pictures paint a
thousand words so and I use different
color pens and he knows who he is yeah
it's like this whole thing but you do
something with our the leader of our
country and that might help I'm sorry
exactly sorry I'm sorry
leader is already pushing at I'm sorry
um
since we started with United finish
we'll just talk about collaborating with
Eric but I think the fact that these
characters are all well well around that
was what was so amazing about this
character for me and when I read for it
and with my ethnicity it's very
difficult to find the character
you're Hawaiian right yes yeah came from
Hawaii is very difficult it's very
difficult to come across a character
which is so in-depth and and like an FBI
agent and also not talk too much about
culture or religion you know this guy is
in the American FBI agent Hawaiian from
a Hawaiian active actor FBI agent and it
was amazing it was about you know family
and about his job and Eric could have
already done such an amazing job with
this character and flashing him out and
who he was and what drives him and what
he's looking to do that it was it was so
easy for me to to do and then when
Vincent drew the pictures and really
explained to me what's going on it was
it was really a great great character
like for me it's it that for me it's a
role of the lifetime it's a play this
game is really fun we had a lot of
really good scenes together for me too
you know he writes this Eric writes of
stuff that's so good that there's hardly
any discussion about it I mean there's a
few things here and there that we talk
about on the phone or we talk about in
person about but you know it all just
makes such good sense that you know I
always look at it you know this way you
could tell it's a good script if it's if
it stays with you like if you can get
the words under your belt quickly you
can tell it's written well and a lot of
that was like that from me on this on
the season memorization was really easy
everything and we had like huge scenes
and big monologues and you know but it
all kind of you know you can tell that
it's a good script when it's easy to
hold on to then you're had an easy to
perform you know all day it makes a lot
of sense yeah for you guys well one of
the things that Eric did sort of give me
a general idea on was sort of meeting
fog ease family and kind of getting into
that kind of stuff so that was pretty
exciting for me
and it was awesome to have some new
faces and then we had a bunch of our old
crew back from the first season so that
was really awesome but Eric was great
man he feel like he's sort of sat down
with everyone before the show and sort
of asked what they wanted to see from
the character and and then he just
really great job well for me yeah well I
was being a stranger to this is genre I
didn't really know what to expect but
then when I read it I was kind of amazed
at the depth of character development I
did I thought it was going to be you
know I mean I had heard about some of
the action stuff and all of that and but
I had no idea that it was so character
driven and the scripts are wonderful and
and I think I you know I'm total
agreement I mean it good scripts and
we've hardly any changes that they
weren't necessary and and just a just a
pleasure to get to work on thank you all
so much I cannot wait to finish the
season seriously have a great day
you